today we're excited to have professor
regina nuzo with us
as a deaf woman regina's journey up has
been anything but easy and from earning
her phd in a male-dominated field to
writing about sex science for a major
newspaper and learning how to hear new
sounds with a cochlear implant regina
has consistently blazed her own trail in
the pursuit of her passions
in this keynote regina will share her
story she'll share the challenges she
faced along the way lessons she learned
and advice she has to offer
regina is an expert in storytelling
using data analysis and statistics
her work has been featured in nature los
angeles times new york times reader's
digest new scientists scientific
american and more and currently she's
teaching statistics in american sign
language at gallaudet university the
world's only liberal arts college for
deaf and hard of hearing students
thank you for being here regina
and i'll now pass the controls over you
after which we'll have a q a session so
please feel free to continue to submit
questions
regina
please go ahead and present
wonderful thank you so much jackie for
the invitation
to come and speak i'm honored i'm
delighted
you know i thought about today
any words of wisdom and pieces of advice
and i'm not sure i have too much wisdom
but
i do have a story to tell
and
some of the things i decided to talk
about for this story it's really the
first time
i'll be talking about them in public
so i really appreciate that we have this
lovely space for me to do that and thank
you all for listening and being here for
that
so jackie said i am deaf
what is it what does that even mean deaf
i never know how to identify myself how
to label myself is it deaf is it hard of
hearing is it
hearing impaired is it
someone with a cochlear implant is it
cyborg
you know it's it's not easy i get it we
need labels we need
identity in the past
we all would have known each other you
would have known me we'd be in the same
neighborhood
and you would have more nuanced
information about me what what did i
hear did i grow up signing
um
what what does that even
my background you would have you would
have that and i would have that about
you so i get that we need to have these
these categorical labels um
and identity but that still makes it
difficult especially when they're
they're categories when they're these
rigid categories
so
my question is well def compared to what
or to whom right um i'm a statistician i
got my phd at stanford and statisticians
are always saying well compared to what
who's your control group um
and
you know because compared to animals
like
dogs and cats and bats
we are all very hearing impaired
did you know i discovered this when i
was looking at cats can hear the
electrical outlet when you plug in like
your hair dryer or lamp or something
before you even turn it on they hear
that buzzing they have an immense range
of hearing that we don't have so
i'm wondering whether cats are always
you know going around secretly pitying
us
or being so deaf and not being able to
hear all the beautiful things in the
world that they can hear and you know
cats it's uh it's probably true so for
me i was born with about half the
hearing that most babies would
and i could hear
the low frequencies but not the high
frequencies i could hear that means i
could hear things like
[Music]
dogs and thunder
and
vowel sounds but i couldn't hear the
consonants the high-pitched sounds um
rain spurged i couldn't hear birds the
birds was actually
the way that they found my hearing loss
um
i was about four and my mother said hey
because you know the birds beautiful
this morning and i said birds mom birds
don't make a noise they never heard
birds i didn't know they made a noise
so
um that was where they caught it this is
my audiogram it doesn't matter if you
don't know how to read an audio grammar
this is an example of my audiogram
um
perfect hearing would be a straight line
up at the up at the top on the zero
hearing loss
and you can see where mine was going
down so everything under the curve i was
able to hear this is my audiogram when
it was probably about six or so
so you can see that i had the low
frequencies but i pretty much had none
of the high frequencies including the
birds the problem is that those high
frequencies those consonants are where
so much of the information for words are
so
um might tight light fight
if it's important that i distinguish the
difference between them i couldn't hear
them it was just i and if it was in
background noise i would lose it
completely
just gone
so this is uh
my audiogram when i was about 20 you
know as losing hearing over time the the
graphics are nice
they explain why i was able to learn how
to speak because i have these
you know these low frequencies these
vowels um but i would mispronounce or
not pronounce the high frequency things
things that i didn't hear or i couldn't
see on people's lips
it's also kind of fun to look at
what's called a spectrogram so again you
don't have to worry about
reading it um
this is a spectrogram of someone saying
19th century fun difficult to pronounce
so the frequencies are along the y-axis
and
time is along the x-axis and the the
color is it's a heat map shade intensity
or the volume
so this is what
a person
with normal hearing would hear
kind of all of these colors coming forth
they wouldn't be able to hear that
when i was a kid this is this is what i
heard
like blankness
and then a tiny little bit
i made great use of that tiny little bit
of sound um i was really good at
guessing um reading people kind of
understanding what they might be saying
and bluffing and getting by
this is uh
my spectrogram after i lost more
hearings about when i was 20. so it was
just going down and down
and
you know my parents didn't really know
how much i was struggling
or how much i was missing
and they sent me to normal school
no sign language no special
accommodations
and
you know philosophically i find it kind
of interesting to look back because
i didn't know what i was missing either
i think it's this way with a lot of
things
how do you know what you're missing if
you've never experienced it before
like you all are not going around
sad and depressed because you're not
hearing what your cat is hearing i
wasn't either i just didn't know there
was this whole other world and
theoretically i knew but you know it
wasn't wasn't really
not until
several decades later
that i
as an adult middle age got a cochlear
implant
and then was able
to get more
sound and to
really realize how much i was missing
and have so much sympathy for my younger
self and
it's hard it's hard a deaf friend of
mine described it as
doing crossword puzzles in real time
where
you constantly having to fill in the
blanks and the you know the clues and do
these mental gymnastics or like your
giant machine learning algorithm
except there wasn't a
supercomputer i was just a tired you
know little girl so i would go to school
every day
and not hear my teachers
and look down at the book of my lap and
just read it's probably a good way to
get an education or
not horrible
now we'll go to the lunchroom in the
cafeteria and the
cacophony of kids shouting and talking
to each other and building connections
and
i i just
i couldn't understand the thing so it's
a little emotional i couldn't understand
so i was so isolated being in that
situation i was i didn't really have
friends um
and then to top it all off i would go
home and then pass out with fatigue took
a nap just from the bare minimum you
know trying to get by
still
i loved school i loved it
i mean it's
no surprise that i gravitated towards
math and
reading because these were things in
black and white they didn't didn't
change things in the air were just
not reliable they were coming in and you
know they it was like um
it's like they weren't real they were
ephemeral but things i could read and
see
um
so
you know
thinking about math and reading
have you ever in your life
realized scenes in your life but only in
retrospect you didn't realize kind of at
the moment what was what was guiding you
what was there
one of the themes for me has been
communication
and it's precisely because i
could never take
clear communication for granted because
i was
so
confused all the time by the world and
left out and you know all this
information
i studied engineering at university of
south florida
and um it was it was hard depth wise um
big
auditoriums i couldn't even read lips
now
um
it got a little better when i was in the
upper class
you know that often i was the only
female in the class and i think a lot of
you know what that experience is like
not a whole lot of fun not nurturing or
warm i didn't have a whole lot of
support
in that way
but i was drawn to statistics
and i think part of it again part of the
theme
because statistics
does in a sense what i was doing what i
do
every day which is
take this mess of
complicated messy incomplete information
that you're getting
from the world
and somehow
parse it figure it out figure out what
the universe is trying to tell you what
it means like what reality is underneath
all of that
do something with it um
some ways that's a terrific metaphor for
my
you know my hearing loss and in how i
was dealing with
with deafness
um so i went to
stanford for my phd
and in statistics
and i think this is one of these again
one of these examples of this theme or
about me taking
[Music]
pieces in my life you know what it is
and
obstacles or brokenness or feeling of
brokenness and
not being something i need to overcome
or embrace or something but in a whole
different direction taking it and
creatively
integrating it into my life into who i
am
in ways that make sense to me you know
when they are
personal and universal so i came
to stanford for my phd in statistics and
that was life-changing i have to say and
it's not just because i'm speaking to
people at stanford it was amazing i mean
it was hard it was very hard um now it's
just a whole another level of hard
we all suffered my cohort was brilliant
and everyone suffered
you know amazing there um
still good friends with a lot of them i
got i got through with a lot of support
from the people that i met at stanford
is still good friends collaborate with
them
at stanford you know i didn't
there's no textbook to read um the
faculty were the textbook they were
better than the textbooks there was
nothing to read you needed to get
everything from them so it was um it was
challenging
my hearing loss was also
going down fast um at that time
maybe after this stress i don't know
they call my type of
hearing loss
a
ski slope hearing loss um because it
kind of resembles the ski slope and you
can just see year after year these
audiograms
that
that slope just crumbling and rotting
away and eroding it was tough so it was
at stanford that i got my first pair of
hearing aids they didn't work very well
in the 70s you know growing up and i had
an odd type of hearing loss so i got my
first pair of hearing aids that was
great
i also learned about assistive
technology and that was the first time
that i found out about real-time
captioning of the transcriptionist like
we have today a human who would sit and
do the phonetics of what they're hearing
and words would magically appear in the
laptop between us so i requested that
for
my weekly biostat seminar and
that was great some of the professors
would come and
sit next to me kind of look over my
shoulder i think these sorts of things
universal design you know captions help
a lot of people you don't need to
you know have a deafness
um
i also started learning
american sign language at stanford with
a fabulous instructor cathy haas who's
deaf
she was amazing it was my first real
exposure to
deaf culture
and asl and all of that i've been so
busy exhausting myself trying to fit
into the hearing world that i've never
really explored this
this you know this other thing and i was
not a beautiful signer but kathy is like
the best instructor she gave me my sign
name and
just kind of she planted the seed
that very gentle seed
um a patient that didn't sprout until
later and i think sometimes
that's what we need right someone is
just going to plant a seed now push not
try to influence just plant a seed and i
feel like for cathy that was me but it
took years before that really sprouted
so i graduated stanford and was doing a
postdoc at mcgill university
i still had this communication thing on
my brain i really wanted to communicate
and write about statistics i had taught
at stanford i loved it and i wanted to
connect for the broader audience
and a friend of mine was doing the
science communication program at uc
santa cruz and um basically they take
scientists and then nine months turn
them into science journalists um so it's
great i went i did that
i loved it
it's a little bit of an odd career
choice though on the face of it so
to be hearing impaired and yet
do a job that requires you to listen
um
for a living so i had to learn how to be
creative about that i worked at the
monterey herald um
throughout my my time in the school
there and
i i
much preferred to do the stories about
ladybugs and sea lions and
grunion fish on the beach and then the
ones with people because it was easier
to interview the ladybugs
um i went to this
desalination town hall
and um you know covering it for the
herald and supposed to come back with
quotes of what people said
at the
at the meeting and i couldn't hear a
thing i came back with a notebook that
was
nearly completely blank
luckily i had a wonderful editor who
just was very calm and let me square in
the eye and said do we need to kill the
story that would be a bad thing telling
the story luckily we were able to cobble
it together um
but
that that was not for me
um i prefer doing other things and the
the thing is i was
trying too hard to be like other people
right or that you know a model of what a
journalist was supposed to do
instead of
um being more like me
with all this you know wonderful
um
imperfections so there's a thing um
what is it called kinsugi golden repair
and it's this idea that
you know you have you have something
that's broken but rather than these
pieces but rather than getting rid of it
just tossing it out
um you
repair it with this lacquer that
is tinged with the shiny gold
platinum or silver or gold or something
and you have something that is
beautiful and strong in its own way and
yes it doesn't look like everyone else
or do things like everyone else but
it is itself it is
its own
bowl and that was what i needed to do
with journalism
um
[Music]
i don't want to call it a secret
superpower but it um
it was mine it was it was those bits
that i was
most missing or deficient on
that became
my source of strength
um so
i
i i instead of being you know this
perfect journalist i was a journalist
who could not hear very well but i was
very good at listening
and what does listening mean so i
learned to listen in other ways i
learned to listen just for the couple of
good quotes i didn't need all the quotes
or i realized i could listen better when
i was interviewing someone if i did all
my research ahead of time so i read
everything you know written by a
researcher
before i went to interview them and then
i'd be able to ask them all the great
questions
that other journalists may not have even
thought to do because they hadn't
needed to you know compensate and do
this other thing or
um my writing instructor said
that he thought that i noticed things in
the um
in the scene that maybe other people
wouldn't how
uh someone was nervously twirling their
chair or you know what they were doing
and these are great color details that
you can put into a story so this that
that was me um
i
i had fun with it um
jackie said i ended up writing for la
times and somehow i ended up writing
a big feature story and the science of
orgasms which you can imagine might
been popular especially at the time it
was a little racy at the time but it was
it was straight up science so then i
ended up writing a lot about sex science
for l.a times i was on the today show
talking about
how to use the evolutionary
psychology research tricks to get a date
at a holiday party and the silly things
but it was it was a lot of fun for me
that was
that was um
that was me you know that was taking
these pieces and creatively integrating
them into who i wanted to be
i've done that with other things too so
after against the
writing program i came to dc and worked
for the national academy of sciences as
a writer but i really wanted to write
for a general audience and i missed
teaching
and
gallaudet as it happened is in dc
and had a position open kenya shrek
assistant professor in mathematics
and for those of you that know don't
know gallaudet is unlike any other place
in the world the only
university that is set up expressly for
deaf and hard of hearing students
and um so there was new assistant
professor
um taking on this challenge and it was
strange because here at gallaudet
um i was no longer hearing impaired now
i was sign impaired um
i knew sign language kathy did a great
job but it was nothing like the fluency
i was working with faculty who were
second third fourth of generation deaf
they were native in asl and it's really
hard to go from you know rudimentary
survival skills too let's talk about
advanced statistics um
but but i loved it i love the challenge
because again it's just communication
i love communicating complicated ideas
it's basically what i do as a journalist
and
i love the challenge of doing this in a
in a language asl is just so beautiful
but it is not like any other language
it's spatial it's four dimensional it
doesn't have vocabulary for things
so how are we are we going to talk about
correlation what sign are we going to
use when we talk about correlation what
does it mean what's correlation really
mean i love that that has been fun and i
think
just like being deaf it made me a better
journalist and a better listener
i think that teaching in my non-native
language and
you know this amazing but very
unlike
written or spoken english language it's
made me a better teacher a better
communicator of how to be creative and
force me to think you know about these
sorts of things it also got me
down this path of developing this new
subfield of quantitative communication
so how can we
take numbers and data and talk about
them in ways that bypass the brain
because the brains are notoriously bad
at numbers and just get right toward
that somehow to me this is it's kind of
embodied the same thing is kind of what
asl does anyway so i have one more
example on this personal level of how
this creative integration has worked in
my life and i i don't even know if i can
take credit for it's more like what my
brain did
so um about seven years ago i decided
after a lot of research
i wanted a cochlear implant i wanted to
give it a try i wanted to hear birds i
want to hear birds for the first time in
my life and lots of other things the s
sound um
so
um i'm happy to talk more about the
cochlear implant you know in the q and a
but basically it's this it is i call it
unnamed mine tiny brain computer tiny so
you have a
tiny mini computer is that um
bypasses your damaged cochlea and
directly stimulates your auditory nerve
you know leading to your brain
and
thousands
pulses you know electricity thousands of
times per second that's what's happening
right now and amazingly your brain is
supposed to make sense of all of this so
i did this as a middle-aged adult and
you know i didn't think my brain um
i had no idea if my brain would be
plastic enough um to be able to make
sense of it
so you have to wait three weeks before
you're turned on activated and i you
know went in the room you probably have
seen videos of
you know kids sitting there um
and uh turned it on and she said
something i don't even know what it was
and it sounded so bizarre it was not
even human
it was like alien things being beamed in
my head it was it was so
and then i started laughing and then i
heard that it sounded even funnier and
then that made me laugh more so it was
um a very interesting thing it was also
very painful though so when she did
the s sound finally the s sound i was i
was ready i was going to get it
it um
i didn't hear it it was completely
silent
um i felt it and i saw it
it's like this bright white
icicle being
needle being pierced through my brain
but i did not hear the sound like
completely silent i know what sounds
sound like it was this way with all
these high frequencies so sh sound
sounded like um
i mean it looked like felt like it
didn't sound like anything it felt like
an iceberg so
all the high frequencies so i had
synesthesia synthetic
i never had that before it wasn't until
like i activated that all of a sudden
now
um
all the
you know all the
the
bowels that i had before those low
frequencies they uh they came through as
like colors muddy colors
and uh earth tone colors and all the
high frequencies the ones i never heard
and the ones that maybe had heard you
know when it was much younger they came
through is um these
light chrome this beautiful chrome
edging
around this muddy middle
bright and shiny
felt like a cool breeze
um
i couldn't
i couldn't i couldn't make sense of it
right i had a synesthesia so those of
you that have maybe studied a little bit
about neuroscience probably
have already guessed what's likely to
have happened my brain as a young child
never had exposure at all to those high
frequency sounds and brains are very
thrifty that was valuable real estate
and it was not going to let that just go
vacant
so it was
likely remapped by the visual and the
somatosensory
parts of my brain that were kind of next
door um
only now as a middle-aged adult i was
telling my brain nope we're gonna we're
gonna do sounds um it would be like well
first of all i got so much extra sound
it was like you hearing now what a bat
hears that's how much extra sound that i
got
um but imagine okay um what is
what does ultrasound sound like it's
hard for you to imagine right um
imagine that all of a sudden overnight
you were able to taste it
or
kind of see it or feel it but you
couldn't hear it it was just so
interesting so it was
it was frustrating also
um because i wanted to be able to parse
words and i wanted to hear the s sound
that i can and all these high
frequencies the consonants
so i would just sit with you know my app
it would say a word over and over and i
have to guess what it is you know fight
type might
and
um
the more i clenched and the more i tried
to force my brain into
hearing those high frequency sounds
making them
work
um
the worst like it got and i worked very
hard at this i
studied a little bit about
neuroplasticity and so i um played games
with myself to reward myself i did it
while exercising i had i was into this i
was completely into this yeah because i
wanted it to work and i also was curious
what
what is it like what's going on with my
brain
so i eventually discovered
that i couldn't clench and tell my brain
what to do
um
it was it was just going to do what it
was so i learned to somehow
get into this state
where
i would feel for the sounds
so if it was
um
the word was game
i would
i would hear g at this um this kind of
muddy thing with it
it's like a little like a little crown
or a little cap of gold on top i know
it's weird but um
so when i would
if i would hear game
i would know if it was name or name
but if i if i knew that if i could feel
that it had that that little golden
crown on top then i knew okay that was
game and so this is a bizarre way to
learn how to hear because
again it's like tasting you have to
taste for your sounds instead of hearing
it you have to meld these two things
together
but this is what my brain gave me
because my brain did this golden repair
i think it's really
you know beautiful because this is
actually a great visual metaphor for
what it did it took all these you know
muddy kind of things you know this
broken plate and
edged it all in in gold and stitched it
all up and um made it you know its own
thing
and it was it was beautiful um
eventually
um
my brain and i got along um
and
[Music]
synesthesia started to fade the you know
the lightning bolts and the crazy things
and started to fade and some of these i
miss it um
i'm still able to
get
uh get that feeling back again of of
listening
to music and just um
just crying even silly music because it
had all these
ornate little
visual patterns to it or listening to
someone speak and it was like a
cool refreshing breeze was over
everything because all those high
frequencies i see them as being cool and
crisp i don't know
so um i went from not being able to
participate in conversation at all in a
noisy situation like hearing absolutely
nothing
to being able to survive you know it's
not perfect
um nothing's perfect right my brain does
what it does and and that's it um
but but it's okay i made it
i made it me and i think that's what's
important so you know thinking okay well
how how would i wrap up all this i said
no words of wisdom but
three things maybe um
one could take away from this um
one is that
assembling these pieces you know in your
life creatively integrating them
creatively
um
it's powerful um difficult but but
powerful one of the most powerful things
you can do
and number two
it's ethos
those bits that
seem most broken
um almost damaged almost missing
those are actually the parts that are
the most beautiful and then
the strongest in a source of strength if
you can see them that way
and
three just
i think we are all
capable of so much more than we think we
are
so thank you very much
hi regina thank you so much for sharing
that with us today this is really moving
and inspirational and we really
appreciate your vulnerability and
talking about your story in such detail
and sharing with us your journey
and as you and i were talking about
earlier it just feels so much more
important now
to share that human side of the journey
and to be able to share that with
everyone and have that connection
um
to everybody in the audience please
continue to submit your questions
through the box below the video and
we'll begin our q a portion of the
webinar today we have some really great
questions that have come in for you
regina
um during your talk and
i want to start with the first one that
i feel um
really kind of sums it up and is a good
one to start with um
you've been asked how have you found the
strength to be so open and vulnerable
about your story today
i think that an excellent question how
have i found i don't know i um i was
invited to be here and i i did it um
sometimes that's all it takes
feel like this is this is a safe space
to be doing this i do i do want to say
that um
i don't i don't know you all and
everyone who might be watching this
later i i don't know you um
but i love the idea that this has come
together as a as a community where
people support each other
the other thing is that i didn't have
anyone telling me things about this when
i grew up or even for most of my life
and it's hard
if
no it's easier if you have other
people's stories even if they're not
exactly like your own and i've been
talking about deafness i should say but
i think all of this is a metaphor for
whatever thing
is your thing everyone has the thing and
we all have multiple things um and so
the idea that i can i can share a little
bit of that and maybe other people can
take tiny little bits of that away and
so in a way that's supporting my my
younger self that was you know so sad
and alone and confused but thank you for
the question
thanks regina
the next question is facing so many
challenges in your journey
is there anything in particular that
kept you so motivated and persistent in
achieving your goals and um do you have
any advice or insight to share for other
women facing challenges in achieving
their goals
oh wow so you know just solve all the
problems right now
just go ahead
all right
um
you know when i was at stanford we had a
50th anniversary reunion for the stats
department and all these alums were
coming back and hanging out and i was
talking to a guy who was close to
retirement i don't even remember his
name and i said
any advice for you know a young person
starting out and he said
have your own career the career that you
want not the career that other people
want you to have would think you should
have and he said he always regretted
that he didn't that he followed
expectations and um that actually stuck
with me so we're just gonna pass that
one along again um
that it's
um it's difficult to step off that path
and do something different and to strive
and work but in a way what alternative
do you have trying to be someone else
like that has never worked right so
while it's harder to be yourself in the
end that's the only thing you really can
be
right and
finding your own path
along the way there you go
i know it's right
but true
um another question that came through
and i thought this was really
interesting um with relation to the
pandemic is how has the pandemic
affected the deaf community and are
there widespread changes across work and
education that have helped and or
hindered the community during the
pandemic
oh my gosh do you have another hour or
two because we can do that yeah for a
long time um
first of all there's oral deaf community
people who don't sign in the sunny and
deaf community and i feel like i have
you know a foot in both worlds um
masks
are really really tough and um
for sign language or for lip reading
um
we're cut off from people and when you
can't hear or can't hear very well and i
think everyone just in general
we're social animals we're primates we
want to be able to read a person and all
their emotions and um i'm not
complaining about mask mandates or you
know it's not a political thing but just
um that has been hard i'm not being able
to see people in person you know even
through this i'm trying to look at the
camera but we're not making eye contact
right there's something about eye
contact that's very human um that we're
missing
good things is that we have captioning
you know zoom now we can work from home
and i have captions for my calls and
it's just it's amazing the fact that we
have this so
that has been good i'll just stop there
because again i could go forever you can
uh
if you want if you want to chat more
about that
and um
so a follow-up question that i felt um
was related to that actually is
kind of when things are challenging so
in some of these situations where you
may or may not
um
have
what you need
um
in these conversations these conferences
these meetings um when things are
challenging how do you keep your energy
level up to keep going and thriving
um
beyond your challenges
keep going and thriving you said
is that what you said you're thriving
yes
let's check
um
yeah i feel like the support really
helps um
and having that that small community a
small protected safe community where you
can come and
um you know just complain and get
commiseration and say come on am i the
only one who's feeling this way or i'm
so exhausted i just can't move i can't
do anything
having that safe space where you can do
it um
in the olden days we'd have a community
right like physically there so we don't
have that but the great thing now is
that we can connect over great distances
and asynchronously and get that sort of
support
um but
i'm not gonna lie struggle is horrible
it's hard just because i'm sitting here
talking to you about it that doesn't
mean i'm actually any good at it
for those of us who
do not have a hearing challenge is there
anything that you've witnessed that
we take for granted um i know you talked
a lot about the sound of birds um so i
think that that was probably
very important to you or significant um
so in other words is there an
opportunity that we may be missing um or
that you
feel like we may be taking for granted
oh
everything you know this is this is my
point about once i realized um we're all
hearing impaired i would love to hear
what a bat hears or a cat or did you
know we can't hear low frequencies
because the sound of the blushing the
blood rushing through our vessels would
drive us crazy so we just have this
narrow view of the world but compared um
to people right who have even less
hearing maybe than you do um
definitely birds and music and um
being able to have conversations
and do something else at the same time
so if you only have your eyes and you
can't rely on your ears
i can't multitask i have to give you my
full attention
so i can't just be doing something else
or listening to a podcast or you know
talking on the phone
i'm saying in a way it's good because i
can't multitask but um
you know the same thing
um it would be nice to be able to
multitask um
yeah
what are ways that you've advocated for
yourself um when you
needed more information to do your job
whether that's at school or work
and do you have any advice as far as um
advocating for oneself in those
situations
it's a great question
um after i got my cochlear implant i got
a new experimental kind it was a part of
a clinical trial and
i did a lot of research on how i thought
it should be programmed mapped and
uh
the way that the default didn't really
work for me and um i had to be very very
persistent with my audiologist and say i
know just humor me let's just do it
anyway um and kind of keep shopping
around until i was able to find that um
i think polite but persistent
because if you're not advocating for
yourself other people are not they're
not going to intend you know to run
roughshod over you but people are busy
and um you need to be that small voice
constantly standing up for yourself so i
think what would i do if i were
advocating for someone else especially
someone younger or more vulnerable what
would i do i would i would fight for
them and that's the same compassion i
tried to bring for myself
i we have a couple of questions here
that are
related um so i mean i kind of put them
together here but
one person asked what your advice would
be to women who have um challenges and
may feel isolated in some way and there
was another question regarding
um
you know any mentors or sponsors that
showed up along the way to help you and
so i think that kind of ties into what
you were just saying about having that
like support system
um do you have any thoughts on that or
or advice suggestions
yeah
it's so hard i was not trained how to do
that growing up in my
culture and that generation and just
where i was florida engineering they
were not big about women's empowerment
is that that time in that area um so i
didn't get practice doing it i think
it's it's hard it's like anything else
finding the right fit um so
you can try to reach out to other
um you know women i know that this group
has a slack right so trying to reach out
to people that that might be
good for you to go offline and create
some more support and if it doesn't work
out for whatever reason there's nothing
wrong with that you know you you just
need to have that magic clicking so i
think um a desire to do it and and to
realize that it's it's not like it's
just magic and then i found a mentor and
they were just standing in the street
and i picked them up and that was that
right um it doesn't work that way at all
i think after the fact it's very easy to
make it seem like it was you know simple
i think in in reality there's a lot of
trial
and error and just trying people
approaching them and willing to be
vulnerable
and
stick yourself out there and
willing to be just wholeheartedly
supportive for another person so of
course the idea of a support is not just
what i'm going in there to give but you
give
by
you get by giving as well that's um
that's the whole 12-step motto right we
we help other people by telling our
stories and helping them um we also
benefit
and then it do you have any
um
any practices that you use like goal
setting or working with your mentors or
coaches or mindfulness or anything
that's helped you
um in your directions and to overcome
some of your challenges like can you
share with us some of your practices um
when you're feeling like you are
challenged um
yeah
um the chocolate count um
chocolate counts
[Laughter]
a lot of exercise you know happy habit
um i read once a famous writer i'm
forgetting who a female writer
said i make my life very very orderly so
that i can be wild and creative and
chaotic in my work um and that was that
was part of her signature style and i
like that a lot by creating these
you know these boundaries and this
regularity then it gives us freedom to
be
uh crazy within that um
i'm also a big fan of paying people
money to help um
to uh get help um
um
so asl tutor right we'll pay a good asl
tutor a lot of money because first of
all i have that human connection so that
is just amazing it's worth the money
um i'm working now with a voice teacher
who is amazing and i have to say is one
of the most
vulnerable and difficult things um i've
done and finding the right person who
could guide me through that um is just
so
valuable and it's something reassuring
taking it out of your own responsibility
or your hands right and saying
okay here betty ann i'm making myself
vulnerable i'm handing it all over to
you just tell me what to do help right
um it's hard to do that very hard so i
know that i've said okay be rigid and
and be organized but yet you know
completely give up control um so maybe
it's a delicate balance between the
two so
um there was a question asked um
that now that
you can hear
um curious to know if you still prefer
to read information or if you would
prefer to listen um how do you prefer to
receive information now
that is a great question so i always
have to say you know here with air
quotes because this is definitely
not like i have a feeling that if you
heard what i'm hearing you would just
say that it's disgusting and that is
horrible but for me it's beautiful so i
just have to say here we're tricking my
brain into hearing um and it is
beautiful i still have some of that that
sense it's in seizure you know that i
talked about um it's funny um i think i
think this is a human nature thing um
have my
tiny tiny on all day tiny brain computer
my hearing hardware
and it's just like oh so much noise and
it's so nice to take it off you know
like the tight bra
shoes and something keep it off at the
end of the day
oh it's just quiet silence right where i
treated myself and just read and you
know just
be in nature
and then i'm like but where are all the
noises in the world now i know there are
all these noises where are the birds
where are the things and then i you know
i missed it and i put them back on and
whoosh then
so i think no matter what i'm always
appreciating
um jumping between those worlds i think
i'm always going to enjoy written
english because i feel in some ways
that's my native language even more than
spoken english
but boy sound is beautiful music is just
just amazing people's voices amazing so
i will never tire of the novelty of that
how about that
no that's a great answer
um and
i think another question would be
is there anything that we can do um
to communicate better with those who are
hearing impaired and i know that i work
with you a lot um so i know some of the
things that um make it easier for you to
participate um that we may or may not
have thought of before that we might
take for granted and sometimes i feel
like we miss
accommodations that we should be
thinking of um when we are hosting these
webinars and things like that is there
anything that you can share with us that
makes it easier for you
that that is a great question so um
first of all um i don't think should
things that we should be doing i don't
know about that that bird should yeah
because
yeah but um everyone's deafness is
different so if i have grown up native
in asl then i would prefer not to have
captioning i prefer to have someone in
the signing for this so um everyone's
needs are going to be a little different
so i think creating the sort of space
where people feel comfortable coming and
saying you know what would really make
this experience top notch for me is if
you had an asl interpreter um
or
captioning or um could you make sure
that you describe your background right
so if you're low vision sometimes it's
nice for me to be able to describe
myself and my background and what i'm
seeing so things like that to be able to
give people the freedom and
be comfortable
coming forward and saying hey this is
this is really um
what i would
what i would like um and it's hard to do
that but i think um you can signal that
in a lot of ways and i think signaling
just like you have here like
we had a request and and we're doing
this and so that hopefully will allow
other people who have requests or needs
to put that in i also want because i
know um it's hard some people get
tripped up i started out by saying what
do i call myself and i didn't say what i
want you to call me and i know people
say
hearing impaired or hearing challenges
or um i've spoken a lot with people with
different kinds of disabilities and we
all agree that it's awkward and we don't
know what to call each other and other
people don't know how to describe us and
don't let that awkwardness over
whatever my differences may be or
whatever words you know i use to
describe myself um
don't worry about that don't allow that
to get in the way of this human
connection um doing your best being open
and curious and warm and wanting to meet
me halfway
um it's so valuable it makes up for so
much um so i just wanted to put that in
there and and for people with
disabilities that i've talked to they
they agree with that that it can be um
awkward but just go ahead don't don't be
afraid of that
so really
you know i'm hearing that it would it's
just most important to create a safe
space where people feel comfortable
advocating for themselves or asking for
what they need because everybody's need
might be slightly different
and really having that safe space or
environment where they feel comfortable
to do that is is maybe the most
important thing
yeah that's a great point
um
so
another question was what drew you to
journalism especially considering that
it's largely based around listening what
was your draw why was your passion
journalism
yeah
yeah um i think that communication thing
i think my brain
um it's just desperately i was always um
you know felt isolated and confused
about what's going on around the world
so what is my solution to that i'm gonna
learn about the world and i'm gonna i'm
gonna explain it to other people and
it's in a way that i can control um
because it's written english and it's me
giving them the information but i love
it when readers would would write to me
or respond to what i had had written um
so it's a form of communication you know
in a channel that i could
manage and i love connecting with people
i love hearing people's stories
i love listening to people's stories i
can't hear them
i can hear them better than that um
and there's something that is so much
fun about interviewing a researcher and
finding out what makes them tick and
figuring out how to get that nugget of
that out and share that with other
people
um other people but i know
a lot of oral deaf people are terrific
writers and i think for that reason it
kind of uh turns you inward in and
playing with language in a different way
we had an a stats question come in um so
speaking of stats how many how what is
the percentage of um people who
gets uh synesthesia after a cochlear
implant implant do you have that um
that statistic
it um
it um is is very small i've never met
someone else who has had that so i don't
know if it's because
um i'm going around
i was on facebook oh um so we had
something i think in the resources or
the q and a that we can drop in for more
information about my cochlear implant um
i think they dropped that in today okay
thank you okay that that had some stuff
that i wrote at the time just sharing
with my facebook friends um
so
i haven't met anyone else that has
encountered that so that might be my
unique brain i know that
people's brains do tend to remap if they
are um you know pre-lingually deaf or
congenitally deaf you know whether
they're missing the sounds in there
the thing is they often are missing all
their sounds and when they try to
communicate to people hey i'm getting
this you know this weird feeling in my
head but no sound i think well-meaning
but ill-advised
specialists would say oh that's just
sound you don't know what sound is and
and maybe be a little patronizing so i
had the ability of kind of having a foot
in both worlds where i knew what sound
sounded like and i knew that synesthesia
weird stuff was not was not normal so i
don't know let's go do a study anyone
here want to just study with me
and then
so are there um
the next question here
um
it are there any challenges that you're
currently facing right now that you have
not discussed um
even aside from this are there any
current challenges that you're facing
right now um and if none what could be
the next challenge that would excite you
so maybe
you're studying here um right right
right um
[Music]
you know i've been so vulnerable already
i'll just go ahead and say working with
my voice coach um
speech is one of the things that is
so
so sensitive to deaf people even deaf
people even have a hard time talking to
each other about um speech and
um
i decided at some point i wanted um
lots of people always asking about my
deaf accent and asking what country i
was from and i would kind of guess all
these eastern european countries at home
as i know i'm from deftly india
um and and finally once i kind of got
that cochlear implant under control i
said all right let's let's see if i can
do this and and you know all these other
accomplishments that i've had in my life
were a bit of a source of sense so i
thought you know when i put my mind to
it i figured out how to do this okay i
had to be a journalist i figured out how
to teach statistics and sign language so
maybe i can do this let's see maybe i
can't we'll find out um so
that um that has produced many many
tears um i've been doing this for maybe
about a year and um
it's exceedingly difficult and
excitingly rewarding and exciting
i'll just leave it at that
that's great thanks regina um i
it looks like this is probably the last
question um that we have time for today
um but could you share what your
favorite project has been so far that
you've worked on
oh
epic one
oh you guys don't think you have to pick
one
oh but now i feel the immense pressure
for it to be meaningful and to
completely sum up all the threads and
themes that i have been talking
about today
and um
that is just not um
true okay how about this i'll go
completely geeky completely different
direction um a few years ago i wrote a
piece from nature about p-values so
anyone in the audience if you know
anything about science or statistics you
know p less than 0.05 and that's the
only thing you remember from stats and i
wrote this great piece in nature
about why it's not really what you think
it is and um that spawn
um not that it was right place right
time but that um
got a lot of attention and started a
conversation about what are we doing
with p-values are we relying on them too
much i don't want to overstate my place
in that but um it was poised for that um
so
uh i don't know how to drop that easily
in the chat but let's just say p values
because it doesn't have anything to do
with anything else in my life it was
just pure
stats geekiness
perfect
okay i think that's the last question
that we have time for today
we'll have to wrap up the webinar but i
want to thank you again regina for
sharing your personal journey with us
today it's really inspirational and we
really appreciate your vulnerability on
this call today um and i hope everyone
on the call um has enjoyed this as well
to everyone in our audience today a link
to the recording of the session will be
emailed to you soon so you'll receive an
on-demand link um so feel free to
revisit the content and again thank you
regina and we wish you all a great week
and we hope to see you all again in
future sessions thank you so much
everyone
you